У Львові пам’ятники охороняють як можуть.
Та чи допоможуть ці заходи - невідомо.
Але точно одне - люди дбають про свою культуру. Війна відчувається і тут. Під Львовом обстріляли військову базу, десятки загиблих.
А от у Івано-Франківську, що за дві години їзди від Львова, поки тихо.
З початком війни ця невелика галерея стала своєрідним
притулком для мистецтва.
Після вторгнення ми почали звертатися особливо до галерей, митців, яких ми знаємо з інших міст України, що ми можемо тимчасово
прихистити твори мистецтва. Тут є митці, які нині тікають на захід України, які поки не планують покидати країну. Їм також потрібна
спільнота інших митців, і вони також хочуть далі бути активними у мистецтві. Ми робимо тут таку собі резиденцію на час кризи, війни...
А також пропонуємо місце для роботи художників.
Навіть коли війна близько, митці хочуть залишатися в країні і працювати над онлайн-виставками. Творити мистецтво разом,
у захищеному просторі - також дає надію.
Надію мало не втратили у Національному музеї у Львові. Цей найбільший музей України пережив Другу світову війну.
Але нині тут остерігаються найгіршого. Витвори мистецтва ретельно запаковують і ховають у підвал.
Ніхто не знає, чи це надовго. Директор,
який роками дбає про колекцію, у розпачі.
На сході України, у Харкові, ситуація значно критичніша.
Будівля Національного музею тут досі вціліла.
Люди докладають зусиль, щоб вберегти
якомога більше робіт, навіть російські.
Іронія долі в тому, що ми рятуємо російські твори мистецтва, картини російських художників від їхніх співвітчизників. Це все варварство.
Світова культурна спадщина також під загрозою, як, приміром, Софіївський собор в Києві, одна із семи пам'яток в Україні,
що перебувають під охороною ЮНЕСКО.
Також Києво-Печерська лавра є об'єктом Всесвітньої культурної спадщини ЮНЕСКО. Вона належить Московському Патріархату.
Та чи зупинить це Путіна?
Я не хочу робити жодних припущень про те,
як далеко щось подібне може зайти.
Статус ЮНЕСКО не зміг врятувати унікальні статуї Будди в Афганістані. Вирізані в скелі буддійськими ченцями, вони вистояли протягом століть.
Поки не прийшов Талібан. Їх повністю знищили на очах світової спільноти. Те саме сталося і в Алеппо в Сирії.
Від історичного Старого міста, занесеного до списку Всесвітньої спадщини, після війни залишилася лише купа руїн.
Гаазька конвенція 1954 року забороняє знищення культурних цінностей. Однак досі за такий злочин було висунуто лише одне обвинувачення
- у Малі, в Тімбукту. Ісламські фундаменталісти зруйнували стародавні мавзолеї та мечеті в 2012 році. Унікальні глиняні будівлі.
Першу і досі єдину справу про такі військові злочини розглядали у 2015 році в Міжнародному кримінальному суді в Гаазі.
Їм насправді вдалося добитися, щоб винного ісламістського фундаменталіста засудили до дев’яти років ув’язнення
та дуже високого штрафу. Тобто є приклади, коли цей інструмент міжнародного права дійсно спрацював, і слід сподіватися,
що це призведе до певного захисту таких об’єктів.
Російські бомби дісталися вже багатьох куточків України. Війна Росії проти України забрала не лише людські життя,
але й багато культурних об’єктів без статусу Всесвітньої спадщини.
Це три тисячі церков, архітектурних комплексів,
будівель, які формували культурну ідентичність людей.
На початку березня росіяни обстріляли київську телевежу.
Поряд з нею розташований меморіал Голокосту "Бабин Яр".
У часи нацизму тут було вбито понад 100 тисяч людей,
більшість з них були євреями.
Ця символічна Стіна плачу за задумом має стати місцем жалоби з цілющою силою кристалів. Так розуміє свій витвір Марина Абрамович.
Мисткиня із сербським корінням виступила проти російсько вторгнення в Україну. Що може зробити мистецтво у цей час?
Треба дійсно думати про порятунок людей. Зараз мистецтво не на першому місці, вибачте, але це так. Є набагато більш невідкладні речі,
які потрібно зробити. Коли я бачу, як бомбили лікарню, виносили немовлят, а жінка вмирала під час народження дитини,
- це набагато важливіше, ніж будь-що інше.
Війною проти України Путін досяг одного: Україна як ніколи єдина –
і готова боротися за свою ідентичність.
А культурні зв'язки з Росією – в Україні у це вже,
здається, ніхто більше не вірить.
Особисто я не вірю в культурний діалог там, де розмовляє зброя.
Тому спочатку війну треба зупинити, а потім усе інше.